humeur festive et envie irrésistible de
gagner petits et grands étaient au
rendez vous dimanche pour jouer à koh
lanta
pas de plage paradisiaque à l'horizon
mais la ville de voisins-le-bretonneux a
mis les petits plats dans les grands
pour reproduire ces épreuves redoutable
au programme pour ces aventuriers en
herbe jeu de réflexion d'habilité et
même un défi manger des insectes quelque
chose de familial et de convivial pour
terminer l'année
la fiche c'était l'école est presque
fini puisqu'il reste encore une semaine
et donc s'était terminée sur une note un
petit peu festive et et sportives
et comme dans le vrai koh lanta les
équipes ont dû s'affronter pour la
finale sur la célèbre épreuve des
poteaux
concentration maximale pour rester en
équilibre le plus longtemps possible
puis vient le moment où il ne peut plus
tenir que sur un seul pied et c'est
l'équipe des nanas qui savoir la
victoire du stress un peu de
concentration et au final mes collègues
sont tombés avant moi donc voilà j'ai la
chance de pas atterrir à un pied pas de
déception pour les autres équipes venus
avant tout pour s'amuser
les poteaux s'est très bien passé
j'étais très concentré mais quand on a
dû passer sur un pied ça a lâché j'ai va
gagner j'étais déçu mais c'était
chouette
retrouvez moi la prochaine saison de koh
lanta sur tf1
parce que je me suis repris plusieurs
fois mais bon j'ai toujours pas été
retenue donc j'espère que cette fois ce
sera la bonne récompense pour les
gagnants une carte cadeau mais surtout
le plaisir pour tous les participants
d'avoir pu partager un moment de
convivialité